el mundo llega a los 8.000 millones de
habitantes todo un reto para el planeta
Pues el crecimiento poblacional es
complejo para el desarrollo sostenible
como lo muestra el África subsahariana
una su región que podría aportar la
mitad del crecimiento poblacional al
2050 y donde hay nueve de las 10
naciones más vulnerables a la crisis
climática por eso se necesitan acciones
ahora unas acciones que en la cop 27
Todavía no llegan por lo menos en los
puntos más difíciles la presidencia de
la Cup anunció que todavía no hay
consenso en adaptación mitigación
pérdidas y daños agricultura género y
mecanismos de reparación y también uno
de los grandes ausentes es el mecanismo
de financiación de pérdidas y daños que
tanto han pedido los países en
desarrollo y que la presidencia de la
Cup no menciona por eso se espera que no
se logre el objetivo de tener un
documento final para el viernes sin los
ministros de los casi 200 países ya
están en charmershake para liderar las
negociaciones más difíciles también los
ministros comenzaron a hablar la Unión
Europea dijo que a pesar de la guerra en
Ucrania actualiza sus ambiciones
climáticas Y promete reducir las
emisiones de gases de efecto invernadero
en un 57% para el 2030 y no en un 55%.
mientras que beliza y Guatemala piden la
inclusión de Taiwán en la convención
marco de cambio climático recordemos que
Taiwán no es reconocido por la ONU como
un país y por su parte El Salvador y
Cuba coincidieron en pedir más dinero
para pérdidas y daños y para adaptación